foreign
driving that cost Diana her life as
inquiries up until now have asserted or
was it murder
media Reports say new information
suggests a British military official was
involved in the princess's death
the information is said to come from the
former parents and law of an ex-soldier
the royal family has not commented on
the news
but a former spokesman to the queen says
he's not expecting any new Revelations
we'll get this every single year prior
to the anniversary of the death of Dinah
Princess of Wales I think the police did
a thorough investigation prior to the
inquest and that's why we had an inquest
the French do the thorough investigation
and they both came up with the same
conclusions I don't think anybody's
doubted those conclusions
investigators concluded that Diana and
her companion Dodie Al Fayed were killed
when their drunken driver tried to shake
a trail of paparazzi
Scotland Yard confirmed that it's now
examining the new information but says
it's not reopening the investigation